but it's a really difficult show to
shoot man we shot 33 episodes in 6 years
33 episodes in 6 years how is that
possible 33 divided by 6 is 5.2 episodes
a
year was it
expensive so you're getting paid the
same as an actor so if you're only doing
five episodes It's not really worth your
time no it became an actual real issue
because there would be so much time in
between between Seasons it just take so
much time and at one point we were like
we have to like fight the studio to like
give us a holding fee or something
because you know Jay Lee was eating
Saltines and Gatorade at one point
because we just couldn't afford anything
it was horrible